[Music]
they're small
creepy
and crawly
but could insects be key to feeding the
world sustainably
by 2050 there will be 10 billion human
mouths to feed our planet genuinely is
on a collision course
so will farming and eating insects help
solve one of the 21st century's biggest
challenges
it's a solution that actually works in a
small village and one day it's going to
reach the store next to you
at one of the world's most famous
museums dr erica mcallister curates the
insects collection at any one moment
there is 10 quintillion insects all
around the world
but she doesn't believe insects are just
for studying
so these are the mealworms this is a
type of beetle and these are the larvae
very thin exoskeleton which makes them
nice and crunchy
dr mcallister is an ento evangelist on a
mission to promote insects as a
sustainable food of the future it is
really weird because we consume
crustacea and insects branched off from
crustacea so these are basically just
land prawns but with their shells kept
on all the time simple as that to
promote the culinary delights of these
creatures the museum even hosts tasting
nights and then you can always pair them
with wine with everything better with
wine
the world is facing a serious food
supply crisis
and eating insects may not be as wild as
solution as some may think
it's an ancient human habit
they found a coprolite a frozen
fossilized poo
containing insects remains so we know
it's been part of human culture for a
long long time today around 2 billion
people choose to eat insects on a
regular basis
more than 1900 species
are eaten across 130 countries
and insects are already legally
permitted in many foods sold in the west
whether you realize it or not
a piece of chocolate you're allowed bits
of insect kiting in the chocolate
because they do fall in they get
everywhere with an estimated 10 billion
mouths to feed by 2050
changes to global consumption habits are
essential
and the real value of insects may not be
as individual delicacies but as a major
source of our most important nutrient
protein
breakfast in the future is less likely
to be bugs on brioche and more likely to
be an insect protein shake
i think within the next 10 to 20 years
we'll be consuming insects a lot more
but not necessarily in the form that we
see here but in the form of pasta such
as insect flour and things like that i
think that's how they're going to be in
our diet
so how much could powders made from
insects help feed a growing population
and protect the
[Music]
environment on the tropical island of
madagascar
the scientists behind one pioneering
project hope many others will follow
their lead welcome to madagascar
biodiversity center
the center is home to valala farms which
produces protein powder from crickets
so she's preparing the cotton balls
and she's going to water it so the
cricket will find a place to lay their
eggs the idea came from entomologist dr
brian fisher every morning i have a bowl
of yogurt
and to it i add
cricket powder this is cricket powder
farmed at valala farms in madagascar
the aroma is incredible
it almost has a chocolate smell and
i take one spoonful which is like 25
grams which is enough for all your
protein and nutrients for the day you
just stir it in
and
it is a nutrient-packed healthy way to
start the day
love it
farming insects is a lot easier and more
sustainable than rearing other kinds of
animals
there are many advantages
to eating edible insects they convert
feed to protein
much more efficiently than cows or pigs
or chickens they require far less water
they don't need to waste all that water
on keeping their body cool
they use less land they're faster to
grow and they're packed with nutrition
we can take advantage of 300 million
years of insect evolution
as well as producing cricket powder
scientists working here are also on the
lookout for other indigenous species of
insects
our team is doing some
lab and field research to find different
potential edible insects across
madagascar
dr fisher created the project in 2006
after years studying madagascar's
declining forests
the scale of the threat from the
country's hungry human population dawned
on him i wanted to explore the forest
and find all the undiscovered insects in
madagascar but along the way i realized
that
these people have no choice if they want
to feed their kids they're going to have
to cut the forest and grow a crop on it
for one or two years today
only 10 to 15 percent of madagascar's
original forests survive and its
endangered species continue to be hunted
for food
global warming is also severely
affecting the food supply here
[Music]
in 2021
madagascar suffered from what's been
called the world's first climate change
famine thousands of people are in brink
of starvation
so that's why we started this project
in response valala farms is scaling up
production and planning to open a new
facility in 2022
[Music]
it aims to mass produce cricket powder
with 54 protein per 100 grams
that's twice the level of protein found
in chicken
the product is already being trialled in
places such as this orphanage where the
insect powder is added to porridge
and where the benefits of qriket farming
are taught in classes
one study in madagascar found a 50
reduction in bush meat hunting following
the introduction of cricket farming our
model madagascar can expand to feed a
millions of people in madagascar but
also could expand to feed 5 million
people in africa
the same
system will work in almost anywhere
there's food insecurity biodiversity
issues and climate change
it's a solution that actually works in a
small village
and one day it's going to reach the
store next to you
but there is a fly in the ointment
for insects to hit supermarket shells in
the west and beyond
farming will have to be industrialized
and scaled up enormously
there will need to be a lot more
factories like this one which food
company aspire is building in canada
and in this building there will be over
90 000 bins each of which will contain
approximately thirty thousand crickets
today the insect protein market is worth
one billion dollars
while that figure is predicted to rise
to eight billion dollars by 2030
it's still a fraction of beef's
333 billion dollar market value
they were actually supposed to paint my
wall in the opposite side or at least
put the electric conduit in the office
[Music]
the ceo of aspire believes they've
already discovered ways to scale up
quickly and challenge more established
parts of the food industry
in the 1950s the average chicken when it
was harvested at 56 days old was just
under 2 pounds
in 50 years you've taken that same
animal and you've managed to quadruple
its size
when we first started in 2015
we were producing one tenth of the
number of crickets we now produce from
the same unit of production and we're
able to
shorten that process of achieving those
efficiencies far greater than any other
form of livestock animal
technology will be key to increasing
productivity
ai and automation will help produce a
tightly controlled environment
when you farm outdoors you don't control
virtually anything
when you farm indoors because you're
able to calibrate and control all of the
variables that impact the growth of
insects temperature humidity sound
pressure light intensity and so this
allows for a self-optimizing production
model and there's virtually nothing in
the world like that today but to take
off the insect farming industry is going
to need friendlier laws
in 2021 the eu permitted humans to
consume mealworms
and industry advocates hope this will be
the first of many decisions to open up
the market
in most countries around the world
insects are already widely consumed as a
food source
what's new here is that we are
formalizing and in many ways
standardizing the production of this
protein source potential economies of
scale offer another way for insect
farming to challenge the inefficiencies
of traditional and environmentally
unsustainable animal agriculture so our
first harvest we're expecting to be mid
next year and then i'm really gonna be
busy yeah yeah yeah for sure make sure
you get all the sleep you need right now
our facility today that we're building
that's gonna come online next year
is situated on 12 acres of property now
according to the usda 12 acres is just
about enough land to raise approximately
three or four cows three or four cows
means you're producing maybe maybe you
know a few thousand kilograms a year of
meat from that 12 acre parcel of land
we are going to produce 12 million
kilograms a year of crickets from 12
acres
farming and eating insects at scale also
has the potential to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions from food production
crickets produce around half as much
carbon dioxide per kilogram compared
with chicken fun fact crickets don't
actually emit methane so their
greenhouse gas emissions which are
already low are even vanishingly smaller
as a result of that
but there's a very long way to go before
insects come close to challenging
livestock and other food industries
supply will need to increase
dramatically
part of why adoption hasn't been more
forthcoming is a lack of scalable supply
in order for you to be able to meet the
volume requirements of some of the
largest food companies in the world they
require
thousands upon thousands of metric tons
just to be able to launch in some
markets with one product i mean the
combined output of our entire industry
today doesn't even meet that
insects could crawl into many more foods
from protein bars to pizzas
whether insects become a staple of the
global diet may depend on many factors
from climate change
to
psychology the 1970s
eating raw fish was unthinkable in many
countries
but today sushi is found on supermarket
shelves across the world
there may yet be a change in the global
appetite for insects
[Music]
thanks very much for watching you can
read more about the future of food and
my technology quarterly by clicking the
link and please don't forget to
subscribe
you